>>> OKAY.
SO, HERE'S THE BREAKING NEWS
WE'VE BEEN TELLING YOU ABOUT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
CONFIRMING TO WANT THAT ONE
PERSON IS DEAD, ANOTHER IS
INJURED AFTER AN ACCIDENT ON A
MOVIE SET WHERE ALEC BALDWIN
FIRED A PROP GUN.
THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE SAYS IT WAS
AN INVESTIGATION AND NO CHARGES
HAVE BEEN FILED.
SENIOR NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT IS
SARA SIDNER IS COVERING THIS
STORY FOR US.
WHAT AN AWFUL STORY, SARA.
>> IT IS UNREAL THAT THIS HAS
HAPPENED WITH A PROP GUN,
ACCORDING TO THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
WHAT WE KNOW SO FAR IS SADLY THE
DIRECTOR OF PHOTOGRAPHY, A WOMAN
WHO IS IN HER EARLY 40s,
42-YEAR-OLD, HER NAME I NOW HAVE
AS HALNA HUTCHINS.
THIS PROP GUN THAT ALEC BALDWIN
WAS APPARENTLY HOLDING, IT WAS
OBVIOUSLY FIRED.
THEY'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT KIND OF PROJECTILE CAME OUT
OF THE GUN.
BUT THERE WAS ALSO THE DIRECTOR
OF THIS FILM THAT HE WAS WORKING
ON CALLED "RUST" THAT THEY ARE
FILMED.
48-YEAR-OLD DIRECTOR GERARD SOZA
HAS ALSO BEEN HIT.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT -- WE DON'T
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT ANY DETAILS
ABOUT HIS CONDITION.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT THE DIRECTOR
OF PHOTOGRAPHTYY HAS BEEN KILLE
ON SET IN THIS SEEMINGLY FREAK
ACCIDENT.
WE ARE UNSURE EXACTLY HOW THIS
ALL HAPPENED AND WHY IT MAY HAVE
BEEN -- THIS PROP GUN MAY HAVE
BEEN POINTED AT THE DIRECTOR OF
PHOTOGRAPHY.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW EXACTLY THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FILM WAS SHOT.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT ALEC BALDWIN
WAS REALLY, REALLY HAPPY ABOUT
BEING BACK ON SET IN PERSON.
HE POSTED ON INSTAGRAM A PHOTO
OF HIMSELF WORKING ON THE FILM.
AND ALMOST DISTURBINGLY NOW
BECAUSE OF WHAT'S HAPPENED
THERE'S A PICTURE OF HIM WHERE
HE'S GOT WHAT LOOKS LIKE FAKE
BLOOD ON HIS TORSO.
HE'S SAYING, JUST HAPPY TO BE
BACK ON THE SET.
AND THAT'S SORT OF ALL WE'VE
HEARD FROM HIM.
AND THAT WAS WAY EARLY ON WHEN
THEY STARTED FILMING.
AND NOW WE KNOW TWO PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN SHOT BY THIS PROP FIREARM,
AND ONE PERSON HAS DIED.
AND, YOU KNOW, THE CREW IS
REELING FROM THIS.
IT JUST -- IT DOESN'T SEEM REAL.
>> YEAH.
LET ME JUST -- THIS IS A -- WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING HERE, THE SHERIFF
SAID THAT THE INVESTIGATION
REMAINS OPEN AND ACTIVE AND THAT
NO CHARGES HAVE BEEN FILED.
THIS IS COMING, AS YOU SEE, SARA
SIDNER REPORTING FROM SANTA FE,
NEW MEXICO.
ALEC BALDWIN ON A SET OF A MOVIE
CALLED "RUST," AND THEY SAID
WITNESSES CONTINUE TO BE
INTERVIEWED.
OPEN AND ACTIVE INVESTIGATION,
NO CHARGES FILED IN REGARD TO
THIS INCIDENT.
WITNESSES CONTINUE TO BE
INTERVIEWED BY DETECTIVES.
THAT'S WHAT THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE
IS SAYING.
HALANA HUTCHINS, TRANSPORTED TO
THE HOSPITAL VIA HELICOPTER,
FLOUNCED DEAD AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF MEXICO HOSPITAL.
AND JOEL SOUZA, TRANSPORTED TO
THE KRISTA ST. VINCENT HOSPITAL.
SARA'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO DIG